linear interpolation or lerp is pretty
simple if you've got two numbers doesn't
matter what they are and you want to get
the number halfway between them then
that's a times a half plus b times a
half if you only wanted say one quarter
of the way between A and B that's a
times three quarters plus b times a
quarter and if you wanted to say the
opposite say three quarters of the way
between A and B then that's a times a
quarter plus b times three quarters this
generalizes to an easy formula for a
value of T between zero and one you can
calculate a percentage between them as B
times t plus a times 1 minus t often
expressed as a plus B minus a times T
this is all pretty simple so far but
what's crazy useful is that last
parameter T and let's dive into y
exactly this is a graph of T from zero
to one we'll refer to it as F of t or
function of t meaning that we have a
function that takes t as a parameter and
returns some sort of floating point
value
in this case our function is just
returning T what goes in and comes back
out simple as that we've also got this
little ball so as T goes from zero to
one we interpolate the ball's position
between left and right using F of t as
the parameter delir all good so far now
what happens if we take that function
and instead of just returning T we mess
around with it a bit we'll keep the
start and end values the same for now
that is to say when T equals zero the
function returns zero and when T equals
one the function returns one but now
we'll return t squared or t times t well
the graph would change now you've got
the second curved line drawing over the
top and you put a second Ball moving
left to right but the behavior is
slightly different it takes a second to
accelerate for zooming across this is
illustrating an important concept you're
now shaping the curve and depending on
exactly how you shape it as the ball
moves from left to right it now travels
a slightly different path it still
starts and stops at exactly the same
time but with t times T it takes a
moment to start moving from zero before
racing towards the end point with t
cubed it takes even longer to start up
but once it does it moves very quickly
you can go the other way as well taking
the square root of T which is
interesting because it starts quickly
then decelerates before the end point or
we can use this super handy function
called Smooth step and the plot of the
graph curves just a bit near the start
and end enough so that when you watch
the ball move it starts slow speeds up
and then slows down again giving a
smooth start and stop effect now there's
a zillion different shaping functions
out there there's really no point going
through them one by one instead the
important takeaway is to understand how
they change Behavior you can ease in
ease out go back and forth bounce Etc
just by plugging in a shaping function
and what's even neater is that you can
compose functions by lurping between
them so say I start with x squared which
gives me this nice slow start and I also
have one minus one minus x squared which
gives me a slow finish then I can lurp
between those two functions giving me a
third function which happens to be a
smooth step so congrats you just derived
smooth step now I said this was crazy
useful and it totally is let's say that
you've got two colors well blending
between them is a simple lerp operation
giving you some value between those two
add two more colors down below and then
lurk between those that gives you a
second result now you can go off and
lurk between the two results and voila
you've got bilinear filter the exact
same method the GPU uses when sampling
textures and you can take it a step
further and run the T values through say
smooth step and you suddenly got an
improved version of bilinear filtering
it's really up to you say you want to
pop a UI element onto the screen like
this
so that involves running a balance
function on the UI scaling value or
slide it onto the screen you can apply a
1 minus 1 minus x squared that gives you
a gradual slowdown as it reaches its
endpoint once they're on the screen you
can animate one towards the corner that
doesn't quite look right because it's
just a linear interpolation so the
second one uses smooth step for both the
scale and position and notice how much
smoother it looks those tiny Details
Matter let's get rid of those by
applying a smooth step on the output
towards zero there are some traps to
watch out for most things can be safely
interpolated stuff like positions colors
angle scaling or game specific values
Health distance that sort of stuff but
let's take the case of directions here
we have two unit length directions and
we want to interpolate between them if
you do a straight lurp between them the
result Vector looks mostly okay but
let's look a little deeper I'll change
the angle of the vectors to face further
away from each other and now when you
look at the interpolated Vector you can
see the problem clearly it's getting
shortened pretty badly renormalizing the
vector helps a lot and honestly in many
situations like shaders they just kind
of live with the problem if the angle is
small you'll be okay otherwise you need
to learn about slurp and slurp stands
for spherical linear interpolation and
we won't dive into the math the key
thing to understand is that unit
direction of vectors lie in the surface
of a sphere so just straight
interpolation is bound to have errors
instead you interpolate across the
sphere like the purple arrow is doing
when the angle between the two is small
the error is small but the wider we go
the more problematic it becomes I said
scaling was okay and now here we are
suddenly talking about scaling it's
mostly true until it isn't let's say you
want to zoom in or out on an object so
we've got our little object here and
we'll zoom in and out and the first
thing you notice is that perceptually it
isn't smooth
it feels like you're covering the
majority of the zoom in the first
fraction of a second contrast that to
the right half so on the right we're
doing a logarithmic interpolation
we're taking the log of the values doing
a lerp on those instead and this ends up
feeling way more natural
and of course you can combine this with
say smooth step to get a nice start stop
on top of everything else the scaling
issue highlights the advantages of
linear interpolation through another
space the results can be subtle but
perceptually better interpolating colors
is easy we can interpolate between a
yellow and a blue RGB values through RGB
space and you get a gradient similar to
this but there's a bit of strangeness to
it look at how in the middle here we get
this weird shift through slightly
reddish colors doing the lurp through
linear color space looks a bit better
but it still has the problem but if we
convert the colors to another color
space like say OK lab perform the lurp
there and then convert back you end up
with a gradient that's arguably
perceptually nicer more what you'd
expect if you were to draw yourself
damping is another common use for lure
that is doing an interpolation between
our current position and a moving
position a moving Target
we want to interpolate towards it
following it in essence
and the most common way is to Simply
interpolate some fixed fraction between
our current position and the desired
position every frame but if we split
this into two separate instances with
two separate frame rates you see that
they behave differently because this
isn't frame rate independent almost
everybody then takes the Delta of the
frame time and feeds that into the lure
hoping that solves the problem which it
almost does
you could be forgiven for thinking it
was working
but if we take the difference in the
positions we can clearly see they're
close but there's a difference there
and this is exactly the kind of problem
that's absolutely infuriating to track
down later one real actual frame rate
independent way to learn is like this
T equals 1 minus K to the power of time
elapsed for some K value
the whole reason behind this is
associativity of multiplication for
exponents the general idea is that b to
the power of M plus n is equal to B to
the power n plus b to the power m
so that lerp of a b and t should equal
to say lerp of lerp a b and t and a half
b and t and a half
now this isn't a rigorous mathematical
proof but I've quickly worked through
the expansion here which you can kind of
glance through if you're interested
hopefully I didn't get anything too
wrong here anyway got a little weird
there at the end but maybe you picked up
some tricks until next time cheers